نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد في لبنان
يتواصلوا السجال بين قاضي التحقيق انفجار
مرفا بيروت ومدعي عام محكمه التمييز
ليتحول الصراع الحاصل من طبيعه سياسيه الى
قانونيه حيث افادت مصادر العربيه بان قاضي
التحقيق العدلي في قضيه التفجير مرفا
بيروت ادعى على المدير العام للامن العام
اللواء عباس ابراهيم والعزيزي من الشخصيات
القانونيه البارزه كما افادت مصادر
العربيه بان اللائحه التي اصدرها القاتل
قطار لائحه اولى وستكون هناك لوائح اخرى
باسماء جديده وقد حصلت قناه العربيه على
تواريخ جلسات استجواب المداعي عليهم كما
حددها القاضي طارق
بمجرد ان حدد هذا التحقيق انفجار بيروت
جلسات الاستجواب المدعي العام والقضاه
المتهمين ردا النائب العام اللبنانيه
قال يدك مكفوفه عن التحقيق بانفجار بيروت
وفي اول تعليق اللي ميلي حسبي الله على
عوده القاضي طارق بيطار الاستئناف في
مهامه في التحقيق بقضيه تفجير مرفا بيروت
وصف المعاون السياسي لزعيم الميليشيا حسين
الخليل انا ما يجري في ملف المرفا هو من
النقاط السوداء التي اصابت القضاء
اللبنانيه
[موسيقى]
مناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من بيروت اللي
محفوظ القانونيه ورئيس حزب التغيير
الاستاذ الي اهلا بك معنا الى هذا الملف
من ملفات نقاش بانوراما لهذا المساء مساء
الانوار
في الحقيقه جدليه ما يحصل الان في خصوص
ملف
بيروت
اسئله قانونيه من له الحق في فرح هكذا
تحقيقات في طرح هكذا
نقاط تخص هذا الملف هل هو قاضي التحقيق او
المدعي العام لدى محكمه التميز
حتى ما حدا يضيع الراي العام اللبناني
والعالمي وحتى الاعلام ما يوقع بهذه
الحيره اقول انه الوضع في لبنان مسيس بما
فيه الملفات القضائيه لنسلم بهذه
المعادله لانه كلنا بنعرف بانه منذ لحظه
وقوع هذا الانفجار وحتى اليوم هناك
عمليه
كمش من قبل او قبض من قبل ميليشيا هيمانت
ليس فقط على هذه الجريمه لانه ورتت نفسها
من دون ما حدا او قبل ما حدا يتهممها
اثنين قبل ما احكي وقبل ما اجاوب عن سؤال
حضرتك نعم
بدي اسكر بانه احد عناصر هذه المليشيا دخل
الى قصر العدل وهدت قضاه بموضوع التحقيقات
التي كان يجريها المحقق العدلي 3 هون
بالقانون بدي اقول بانه المحقق العدلي له
سلطه عليا ولا سلطه تعلو على ايه بمجرد
انه
يدير الملف الذي اولي به كي يحقق يستجوب
يستنطق
بوصولا حتى صدور القرار الضمني وهون ما عم
بكشف معلومه اصبحت معلومه من قبل الجميع
انه المحقق العدل طارق البيطار
اصبح اا بالخطوات الاخيره قبل اصدار
القرار الظني الذي سيحدث زلزال على كل
المستويات في لبنان اما التجاذب بالحسين
ما بدي انا ان يعني اذكر بعض الاسماء لكن
غدا بالجبهه السياديه عندنا اجتماع بدي
صنفه بانه استثناء لانه سنضع يدنا على هذا
الملف انطلاقا من الواقع السياسي الذي
نعيشه لكن
بالقانون بدي اقول بانه
القضاء ليس بالف خير في لبنان جسم القضاء
بالرغم من كل سنوات الحرب التي طالت لاول
مره سنشهد وسنشهد تباعا انقسام وراء
انقسام انه اليوم بنسمع
تبادل وتقاذف
وسجل بين القضاه المعنيين مباشره بهذا
الملف وهذا امر غير صحي على الاطلاق يؤشر
الى تطورات خطيره بس سياسي بدي اقول بانه
ان شاء الله تكون مخطئ لكن كل المؤشرات
بتقول ان احنا رايحين خلال ساعات او ايام
على مشهدي دراماتيكيه وليست كلاسيكيه قد
تشبه باحد جوانبها ما يشبه سبعه ايار وما
قد يصل الى اكثر من عين الرمانه كما حصل
معقول
لا لما تتحدث عن مستوى او مرحله عين
الرمانه فلنحنا نتحدث عن تطورات
دراماتيكيه وتطورات مخيفه
كل شيء على هذا المستوى ليش قلت عين
الرمانه لانه اصلا غزوه عين الرمانه
انعملت انطلاقا من الضغط على المحقق العدل
ان عملت انطلاقا من الاطاحه بالمحقق العدل
الخطا الكبير الذي ارتكبته الاداره
السياسيه في لبنان بدا منذ لحظه القبول
بالاطاحه بالقاضي فادي صوان اي المحقق
الاول الذي يعين اطيح بفدي صوان وتم تعيين
طارق البيطار وهن عم يسلكوا زيت المسلك
هلا انا ما بدي افوت بسجل من يملك الحق من
لديه الحجه القانونيه لانه السجل
المدني
يعني ابعاده عن المسار السياسي ووضحت نقطه
حضرتك ولكن
بخصوص هذا الموضوع حضرتك تقول بان القضاء
في لبنان هو ده امسيس تقول بان القضاء في
لبنان يشهد انقسامات عميقه وهناك محاوله
لتكبير من يحاولون التحقيق بطريقه جزيه في
اا قضيه مرفا بيروت ومن جهه اخرى تقول بان
القاضي البيطار قادر ان يطرح مفاجات وان
يحمل الملف الى تطورات دراماتيكيه كيف كيف
سيترك لا سياسيا قادر ولا قضائيه قادر ما
الحلول كيف
سؤالك كثير مهم لانه بيردنا على ما حصل
على مستوى ملف ان في همم اغتيال الرئيس
الشهيد رفيق الحريري ياللي بنهايه المطاف
صدر حكم بحق خمس متهمين ينتمون الى بديش
حزب الله اني متورين دولتنا العليه معزه
بتحالها حتى تسال عن عناوينهم لالقاء
القبض لان فاز الاحكام اليوم المحقق
العدلي يشبه الى حد بعيد هذه المحكمه
ياللي راح يعمل واجباته من نهايه المطاف
انا لا اعتقد بانه همم حمايه همم القاضي
بيطار لاحقا ستكون على مستوى محلي لكن
ستكون على مستوى دول واغلب الظن وامل ان
ينتقل هذا الملف الى التدوير القضاء
اللبناني سيكون عاجز عن احقاق الحق في ملف
الانفجار بيروت لانه وهون بده يقول همم
شيء لانه انا لمسته انا واحد النواب
تقدمنا باخبار منذ سنه واكثر بحق التجار
سوريين
على الصله لصيقه ببشار الاسد متهمين بانه
هن بيملكوا نترات بانه هن استحضروا نترات
لكن للاسف القضاء لم يتحرك من ذاك الوقت
مش هناك عم قول بانه بنهايه المطاف رح
يطلع قرار راح يكون في اسماء كبيره بالبلد
تحدث زلزال على مستوى السياسي
الى
اصدار احكام بهذا الموضوع على الموضوع
شكرا جزيلا على الحضور السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]